[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 147 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm Melanie Warrick and I'm here with
special co-hosts Billy rink and yelling
Brucie hello Billy hello yelling hi I'm
Melanie it's nice to be here thank you
for being here all right I'm gonna have
you both take a quick minute and tell us
a little bit about who you are
thanks I'm Billy I am a lecturer at
Stellenbosch University this is of
course also the hosts for the series
deep learning in Doba I have a passion
for machine learning computer vision I
have a passion for teaching and it is
wonderful for me to be here I'm glad
you're here knowing ya I'm Yellin
Morrises melanie has mentioned I
recently joined the Google AI team for
the group that's gonna be played that's
gonna be in Accra Ghana I'm very excited
about that before that I was a
researcher at the Council for scientific
and industrial research countries it's a
very very long name but it's a research
lab here in South Africa government
funded and also partially industry I'm
very very excited to be going to Accra
because I can continue to a
machine-learning and continue living in
Africa which is exactly where we are
here at the endeavor yes we are doing
this recording in this episode
specifically is about deep learning in
Java where we're going to showcase a
couple of interviews that we captured
during this week can you both take a
minute and just tell the audience what
deep learning adop is about our line is
strengthening Africa machine learning so
it's good to start with us but I think
the deep learning in Java has become
strengthening African machine learning
but I think when we started it we did
not know exactly how much it would and
it has become a community of sharing
knowledge of sharing skill of
celebrating one another and of course
continual learning so it almost feels
like it's gonna be our yearly pilgrimage
where from wherever we come from we go
to wherever everybody is and we
collaborate and we work together and we
just we catch help and we celebrate what
we did with the last year yeah and I
think also what is very important for us
is to equip students and academics from
all over Africa to come together to meet
each other to
work but very importantly also to go
back to their own communities and carry
on this message of strengthening machine
learning and yeah really just catching
up with the rest of the world Africa has
enormous potential and I think it's a
very exciting time for all of us
great well as I mentioned we have some
interviews in this episode in particular
we are going to be talking with and Vili
you helped me with this we're talking
about the Essene and we are also talking
with Cosi and we're going to spend part
of that interview really talking a
little bit more about what deep learning
in Davos is about and some of the awards
that were given out and then the other
part of our interview that was covered
was with Andrea whose VC here in Africa
and I know yelling and I just spoke with
her and had a great conversation so
before we get into our interviews as
always we start out with some of the
cool things of the week and a question
of the week and we're gonna wrap up with
a question that is pretty much what are
some of our key takeaways from the
conference but as I mentioned we'd like
to start out with the cool thing of the
week and we're gonna do a little
variation off of this which is to help
talk a little bit about sort of one of
some of the highlights that have been
going on not the key takeaways but
things that have been happening during
this conference where some of the great
things that have been going on or
activities like I know that we've had a
lot of speakers here and yeah so we've
really had an action-packed week great
speakers Nando de Freitas was here and
Mustafa sees and lots of others David
silver Jeff Dean so it's a really really
great list of speakers we also had
poster sessions which were amazing all
the students presenting their own work
movie screenings of alphago right there
was a woman in machine learning event
one evening which was really inspiring
you were speaking at that one as well
yeah and it was a very well attended I
was wonderful our biggest sessions and
then there's been students who are from
all over different countries within
Africa
my understanding is like 30 countries
and the number of attendees is around
550 attendees that's right
outside of the will of nth I think one
of the cool things that I saw was when
David silver walked in and somebody was
sitting there and looked over and saw
him it was like oh my god I just saw you
in a movie I thought that was pretty fun
to watch any other little highlights are
coming to mind I think I also saw
somebody one down at David Silva
spotting and
he kinda lost his mind a little bit the
cool events oh goodness
they are just so many my coolest event
was the award sessions and the posters
are always really rewarding and
enlightening and half the time I mean
you just go there to just learn meeting
all the other people that are actually
machining and maybe that's actually
something to mention about the number of
people that have traveled from far other
researchers have jam-packed a schedule
that travels from far to come spend the
week with us and that's been very
exciting to see them all so very much so
any posters that jump out oh well this
is really putting me on the spot because
the one poster that I do remember was
actually Steve Crone and Herman Herman
is also your colleague who go organize
this and this poster will be at nips
this year's nips poster and they have a
closure they have discovered about how
to add noise in a network so how much
noise can you add in a network until you
can't learn anymore
so actually you saturate the network and
you cannot anymore then in a deep net
and so they have these closure
properties about how deep you can go and
how much noise you can add and that's
really beautiful because so much I mean
that just narrows the parameter tuning
search space I mean this is work that's
been done right here in Stellenbosch
that's great well I think it's time for
us to go ahead and jump into our
interview so let's go do that
today I'm excited to have with me dr.
Volkow see my bothy and Yaseen Musa a
Yami who are both here at deep learning
and dhaba which is based in celibate
South Africa for this edition of the
deep learning in Taba and with me also
is Lilly brink who is helping to be my
special guest co-host so thank you all
for coming today
okay thank you now let me go ahead and
kick us off like we usually do which is
to have you tell us a little bit about
who you are so if a Cosi can you start
thank you for having me over my
background most deep is in kind of
machine learning at the moment I am the
chair of data science and a senior
lecturer at the University of Victoria
taking through my background interested
in a kind of machine learning in AI from
a young age ended up going